Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire
once again filling in for David. You
know, one of the things that we have
talked about a lot with regard to the
January six hearing is whether or not
any of these televised hearings are going to have
any kind of impact on the 2022 midterm elections.
And according to former Tea Party Republican Joe
Walsh, who tweeted out on Thursday, no, they will
have absolutely no impact. Here is Joe Walsh's
tweet. Twitter world may not understand this,
but January six and these hearings won't make
any difference in the midterms. The hearings
are important and necessary, but they
will have zero impact this November.
It's kind of a bummer, right? I mean, way to come
along and ruin everybody's mood, their captain
buzzkill. But at the same time, I don't completely
disagree with them. I do think for the most part,
and I'm struggling to say that because I don't
know how much I believe him or agree with him.
But I do think he's right. If these things do
end up having an impact on the 2022 midterms,
I don't think it's going to be a hugely measurable
impact. Right. It may affect like a couple races,
but I don't think it's going to affect enough of
them to stop what we all see as likely coming,
which, of course, is Republicans taking back the
House. I don't see it doing that. I don't see
enough momentum with this. I don't see enough,
you know, tying it in to the other Republicans,
because the hearings, of course, are all really
about Donald Trump and his administration. Yes,
we've, you know, identified several Republican
members of Congress that were involved.
But even if we took out each and every one of
those people in the elections, Republicans would
still be poised to take back the House. So that
is why I do, again, kind of agree with what Joe
Walsh has to say. But then the other. But is the
poll numbers right? The poll numbers out there
are kind of contradicting it, at least right now.
Here's what they tell us. Nearly two thirds
of U.S. adults believe the January six,
2021 riot at the Capitol was planned, according
to a new Quinnipiac poll. Poll found that 64% of
respondents believe the attack was planned
and 30% believed it was spontaneous. Okay,
so it's influencing public opinion, which is
great. I mean, that's the whole point of all of
this. We want to influence public opinion, but
not because we're trying to brainwash them or,
you know, push them into any kind of political
ideology. But because we want to influence their
opinion on the people who perpetrated these acts.
And there is a big difference between those two.
This is not a partizan political committee, as
the Republicans would like to have you believe.
This is in fact a fact finding mission. And so
far, a lot of the facts that they found have
been very bad for the Republican Party. So the
question is, could it have an impact on the 2022
midterms in a meaningful way? And the answer is
possibly in order. However, for that to happen,
the committee's work would have to focus
more on the Republican Party as a whole.
You know, not just paint Donald Trump and Giuliani
and some of these other weird little characters
out there. As, you know, the only people they
would have to come back in and tie it all in
saying this, folks, is who the current Republican
Party is. And that's not the job of the committee.
That's the job of the Democratic Party.
And that's where that disconnect exists.
The January six committee has done great work. I
was skeptical of them at first. Didn't think they
could pull it off. They have they have proven
me wrong and I am grateful to them for it.
But now is the time for the Democratic Party
to step up because, yes, these hearings are
impactful. Yes, they are changing public opinion.
But the committee is not going to sit there,
especially with Republican like Liz Cheney
sitting on there and say this is who all
Republicans are. They're not going to do
that. And they shouldn't do that either.
They kind of should, but they can't. I understand.
They absolutely cannot, because you will start to
turn off people. What the Democratic Party could
do should have already been doing. It's turning
some of this into ads. Ads running on national
television channels all across the country.
But they're not. The messaging from the
Democratic Party needs to be that this is
who the Republicans are. Not this is who
Trump is not. This is who Jim Jordan is.
This is who they all are. Every one of them. Yes.
Use that language. Yes. I don't care if it makes
Liz Cheney or Adam Kinzinger or sitting on that
committee angry. This is your opportunity. The
public is paying attention to these hearings.
Millions of people have already tuned in.
The polls are shifting in pretty significant
ways. I mean, rather shocking ways, if you ask me.
So seize that moment, jump on that opportunity,
and put it in ads. Put it in people's faces
every day. Tie every single Republican
candidate out there back to these people.
Because even if they didn't
participate, they still vote with them.
Hell, a lot of the candidates out there running
for office actually support what happened that
day. They still support Donald Trump. That's why
you do have candidates, by the way, like Dr. Oz,
who have now shifted their messaging to stop
mentioning Trump as much. And, you know, moving
back on to just just the issues, folks, don't let
them do that. Don't let them get the upper hand.
Tie every Republican in the country to
everything this committee has found. You do that,
you may have a pretty significant impact on the
midterms. But if the Democratic Party is sitting
there waiting for the January six committee to
do this themselves, it ain't going to happen.
That is not the job of this committee. And
if they attempted to do that, they're going
to lose all the credibility that they have. This
is on the Democratic Party. They could do this.
They should do this. But if history is
any indicator, they won't be doing that.